pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec yannick jacobson secrétaire général
de la cgt santé et action sociale dans
les landes bonsoir yannick jacobson
merci d'être avec nous pour vous aussi
beaucoup de pression inapproprié de la
part du ministre vers ans oui c'est des
propos inappropriés inappropriée et qui
stigmatisent vraiment des personnels
soignants
c'est même des propos quasiment
discriminatoire envers une profession
qui étaient acclamés il ya un an et
maintenant pour une politique vaccinale
qui et les errements insultes on
voudrait faire passer logiquement la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants en se servant de ce qui se
passe à n'est pas de pontonx donc oui
c'est vraiment discriminatoire est il
vraiment une action politique pour bien
qu'on comprenne votre point de vue est
le point de vue de votre syndicat ce que
vous déplorez là ce n'est pas forcément
le débat sur la vaccination obligatoire
des soignants mais c'est cette méthode
peut-être pour y arriver
selon vous oui c'est la méthode on
incrimine des soignants ont déjà à s'en
prendre à la directrice de
l'établissement est aussi le directeur
de la rs de la nouvelle aquitaine est
beaucoup plus prudent sur le porteur du
virus qui a emmené comment dans
l'établissement le virus donc oui j'ai
ramené de la méthode n'est pas
appropriée et le débat aussi d'
obligation de vacciner c'est pourquoi
stigmatiser les soignants dans ce canal
tout le monde devrait être vaccinée
pourquoi pas vacciner les enseignants
les chauffeurs de bus faut rappeler que
la vaccination ne protège pas comment
d'attraper le virus c'est seulement sur
des formes graves et on peut être
porteur donc n'importe qui peuvent
porter il faut quand même savoir que
dans cet établissement il ya déjà bien
réussi
en tout cas été contaminées en début du
mois donc voilà imposer la vaccination
au gouvernement faut pas oublier quand
même que ce même gouvernement il ya
quelques mois imposée aux agents positif
1 symptomatique d'aller travailler donc
deux poids deux mesures et se servir
politiquement dans du personnel soignant
pour faire avaler la vaccine obligatoire
qui après les soignants sera obligatoire
à tout le monde
la cgt n'est pas contre les vaccins mais
bien sûr et compte et pour une liberté
individuelle des travailleurs et
travailleuses à se faire vacciner de
leurs vous vous dites
effectivement la vaccination dans ce cas
tout le monde devrait se faire vacciner
mais vous savez aussi bien que moi que
la profession de soignants c'est très
particulier ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
ce sont tout simplement les et les
nombreux médecins l'académie de médecine
acquis qui parlait même d'une faute
morale on aura un air entendu et lu
plein de médecins qui pensaient cela
c'est vrai que c'est délicat quand on
soigne des personnes très fragile et
âgée de prendre le risque de leur
transmettre le virus
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre
notamment aux familles qui sont
inquiètes
alors ce qu'on peut répondre c'est que
les soignants et les personnels
soignants sont des efforts surhumains
pour protéger la population travaillent
dans des conditions vraiment délétère
peut-être que avoir plus de personnel
soignant
ça permettrait bien sûr d'appliquer les
protocoles plus à la lettre d'être moins
fatigués tête - de faire d'erreur et
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure on
peut comme en rêve porter sans le savoir
déjà d'une vacciner ou non n'importe qui
nourrit pas n'oubliez pas qu'on peut
aller rendre visite à nos patients à des
patients à des résidents le virus doit
être transporté par n'importe quelle
personne donc et stigmatiser encore une
fois la profession de sonia qui a aussi
également perdu
une lourd tribut d'un an dans cette
épidémie n'est pas pété à la chose la
meilleure des choses à faire
enfin tel soignante on ne veulent pas se
faire vacciner sont par exemple suspendu
dans un état comme le texas aux états
unis sont écartés en italie vous trouvez
ça choquant bah oui c'est choquant
n'oubliez pas qu'en france on a déjà une
pénurie de personnel soignant le
personnel qui te laves ira tout va bien
sûr à cause des conditions de travail
délétères qui y sont effectués de ddd
payent des salaires minimums on a déjà
du mal à trouver des personnels
soignants donc bay ou obligeant le
personnel à se faire sony est peut-être
encore faire partir plus de
professionnels donc jean castex qui
entament ces consultations il faut que
d'ici la fin de l'été la vaccination
soit quasi complète sinon effectivement
il faudra prendre nos responsabilités il
parle notamment de la vaccination des
soignants susceptibles d'être
obligatoire ces consultations elle vous
inquiète
clairement aujourd'hui nous inquiéter
oui nous on sait très bien que le
gouvernement
un jour dit blanc un jour dire aux donc
depuis début de l'épidémie même les
profs et les professionnels de santé
c'est sur quel pied danser les
protocoles les normes changent tous les
jours donc on peut plutôt remercier le
personnel de santé
appliqué à la lettre ce qui est dit par
le gouvernement et donc à éviter que
condemi se propage dans l'établissement
est-ce que les protocoles aussi appliqué
bay sont efficaces voilà on ne sait pas
encore donc et puis vous dira tout aussi
tous ces médecins ces professeurs sur
tous les plateaux télé mais qui viennent
peut-être un peu dans les services
trouvé qu'ils retournent vers les
services ou alors comment ça se passe
est obligé d'y obligé la vaccination
mais voilà c'est un
un autre à ma liberté de choisir nous
mêmes merci tmx a comme ça d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur ft france